from the Independent Supreme Court will
decide if Trump can be kept off 2024
ballots after January 6 Insurrection I
love how they just they make an
affirmative statement in the headline
despite the fact the headline is
literally the Supreme Court will decide
if there's actually any question of the
Insurrection in the 14th Amendment
because the argument is if Trump did
engage an Insurrection then the 14th
Amendment would keep him off however
well actually that's not fair that's not
fair the 40 Amendment likely uh uh
doesn't even apply to the president and
we haven't even Trump hasn't even been
charged with any kind of insurrection so
we're nowhere near there but of course
the independent is going to
affirmatively state in the headline
after it already happened but anyway
that's why I used this Source because
you know we love our leftist friends the
reality is the Supreme Court has granted
search to Donald Trump he will go to the
Supreme Court and have his argument the
Supreme Court will listen to the
argument as to whether or not Trump can
be removed from these ballots this could
end the uh the issue one once and for
all so I hope they answer this really
really quickly I don't know when they're
expected to come into session but uh you
know there's a slim chance the Supreme
Court comes out and says actually yes
Trump did engage an Insurrection and so
he's off the ballot and it pulls him off
the ballot everywhere not really going
to happen but that you know look the the
the reason roie Wade got overturned at
Supreme Court is because a group I think
it was Mississippi right where they
filed the lawsuit Mississippi was they
sued because Mississippi was set a ban
an abortion so they sued saying hey you
can't do this and the Supreme Court said
not only can they Roy we's gone
everybody so if they just did not
challenge it and let Missy do what they
wanted roie Wade would still be there
yeah they lost at all so there's a
possibility could backfire but I really
do think Supreme Court's goingon to side
with Trump on this one yeah I think he
backfire actually goes back to back I go
backfire yeah I think the court I think
the Court's just going to say you can't
do that you guys are you guys can't be
thrown presidential no no I meant
backfire on Trump no no no I think
backfire on the lefties know backfire in
the sense that that the the states that
are meddling around I mean Colorado is
not as much of a Target State Maine has
the one congressional district that
sometimes goes goes for Republicans but
it goes back to what we're saying about
the Communist in this country we're not
communist therefore we're innocent until
proven guilty people have heard of that
innocent until proven guilty president
Trump has convict been convicted of
absolutely nothing he's not been charged
he haven't been charged that much that's
convicted so therefore he's an innocent
man under the rule of law nobody has
been charged with with Insurrection have
they conspiracy to commit think what
conspiracy okay I think it was
conspiracy to commit it not actually
committing it okay they were clever with
that but but nonetheless we're talking
about President Trump on the ballot he's
convicted of absolutely nothing and
these are people who claim to be for the
people like really so if an innocent man
because you're innocent will proven
guilty can be thrown off ballots because
you don't like him or because you think
he may have done something I mean this
is this is uh basically chaos what about
what about Santos yeah same thing same
thing nothing either yeah he got he got
that's crazy infuriating but Mendes gets
to stay with gold bars pockets in his in
his how has he not been expelled
yeah didn't they just issue a
superseding indictment I do not know
like oh we got more on this guy yeah
there's a lot Santos has been accused of
a lot of things but he's he's not been
convicted of anything and he gets that's
crazy he's guilty of being awesome the
only two people we ever thrown out
before were actually convicted of
something so that's a different standard
but it's the reason that it happened is
because he is because Republicans are
stupid and because Democrats are crafty
Democrats are more than happy to vote
with of Le and I was there voting less
than half the Republicans voted for that
interestingly enough the new speaker of
the house uh Mike Johnson uh the
majority leader Steve scalise the
majority whip and the everyone in
leadership voted against removing him
against removing him as did most
Republicans but the Committee reported
it out nonetheless overriding leadership
wow yeah so I mean Kevin mcarthy is want
to set up the committee he he resigned
now but the new speaker Mike Johnson
voted against it I don't know how Kevin
would have you know I don't and so
basically what was it how many
Republicans ended up voting it ended up
being like 111 voted no to expel them
including me and about 90 or so voted
yes to expel him so the minority of the
Republicans but every Democrat I think
one abstained but basically every
Democrat was more than happy to throw
him out everyone like I can't imagine
convicted of nothing I well they they I
can't believe that that many Republicans
voted to throw them out I mean 105
Republicans voted to expel ridiculous
how many uh uh let's see um more than
100 Republicans joined Democrats to
expel Santos and uh Newsweek has the
list let's uh all right let's grab a
name it random we're going to just to
shuffle it up a little bit and then Ron
Estus of Kansas you are a
scumbag unlucky guy unlucky uh oh did I
see Dan kencha on there oh God please
Dan kencha Dan you're a scumbag why on
Earth would Dan khaw vote for that I
don't know man is there anybody in here
I I'm I'm I know that I'm going have to
call scumbag because I will I will let
me let me go through if I see uh uh we
Dan uh we almost had him on the show
he's been invited several times but he
canceled on us every time uh he's not a
scumbag for that he's allowed to cancel
on us you don't have to come on the show
nobody owes me any favors but voting to
expel Santos who is not convicted of any
crime is pathetic spineless Behavior
yeah so uh who's who's I I I don't know
if I know anybody in here cuz we like I
we're we mostly have the freedom caucus
people in here I mean you know they they
like to say oh Tim pool's rightwing it's
like like moderate Libertarians on this
show you know what I mean so if it's
like Freedom caucus people we're usually
friends with them and they're usually
doing the right thing we don't got to
worry about them but uh as for the rest
of these people I don't even know who
these guys are Ken Buck sorry Ken you're
a
scumbag Andy Bar
scumbag like you can you can apologize
after the fact all right but right now I
just call you scumbags anyway what we
talking about uh how the Republicans are
unreliable and they will vote to boot
people that are Republicans whereas the
Democrats obviously wouldn't you look at
the way that the like and Grant this
isn't in Congress but it's still the
same ideology the way the Democrats are
flipping out and and making a massive
issue over the firing of uh president
gay from Harvard right they're all
swearing up and down that it's it's
because of racism when the woman clearly
had massive amounts of perjury in her
history and she made terribly
anti-semitic comments in front of
Congress that's totally justified to ask
her to step down especially considering
Harvard has a reputation to worry about
the anti-semitic comments alone are
enough for Harvard to be like you have
made remarks that do not line up with
Harvard's values you need to step down
that you can disagree but at least it
makes sense and to allow her to stay and
and sit there and and and run her and
and you know to to to not have take care
of the problem and and sit there and and
defend her as if she had done has done
nothing wrong as if it's just based on
racism is absolutely insane but that's
the way that they behave there is they
will not go after their their own and
anytime there is a a in the
Republicans armor they're going to go
for it I can't wait you know cuz we got
uh we got elections coming up and we get
more and more elected officials running
for re-election who want to come on
shows like this well they're not going
to come on this show that's not going to
happen people say to me all the time
like Tim you got to be nice otherwise
they're not going to want to come on
your show and I'm like good I don't want
them I mean look you got com on there uh
there there's absolutely people I'd love
to have conversations with but I'm sorry
man if you if if I'm going to be I'm
going to be a dick about it I think I
think one of the scummiest things you
could have done is how they could have
waited they could have been like okay we
got some evidence let's let's let's
let's get it documented as this country
is supposed to do to prove that he's
guilty and then get a unanimous vote and
be like you're guilty of this stuff you
get out of here man instead it's just
it's just guilty until proven innocent
at this point this is a it's a dark path
for this country and I'm sick and tired
of Republicans you know you know you
know I see and you know what so many
Americans see and and I think this is
why so many Americans are pro Trump and
voted for Trump in 2016 and I was late
to the party you you know it but look at
this Republicans get on their knees for
Democrats the Democrats crack the whip
on Republicans say you know please may I
have another
remarkable I will say this i' I'd love
to advocate for the impeachment of Joe
Biden at this point on principal grounds
but strategically please don't impeach
them man we need we let let him stay in
there so he can lose understand impeach
me you still got to convict in the
Senate so so in that case he would not
be removed but he would not be removed
from office and so we can do it then you
could impeach him but you there's no way
he'd be convicted so what I say to
people is look we got an election coming
up here in November so you want to get
rid of him that's that's the best
effective way to do it Missouri state
senator be Bill Eagle sponsored a bill
to disqualified Joe Biden from the 2024
ballot uh Alex posted this Al Alex
posted this uh at 8:22 p.m.
today uh it says uh you know what I I
think i' I'd love to advocate for the
impeachment and conviction of Joe Biden
but I think you're right because we were
for a long time like this guy the
barisma stuff I mean the Border stuff I
I think the border the the the
facilitation of the of the immigration
crisis he's suing Texas now he's
facilitating this I think you can say
this is high crimes and misdemeanors all
that stuff but I kind of think if the
Republicans impeach Joe Biden thinking
hey we'll earn some political points
he'll never get convicted he'll get
convicted Democrats will be like oh gee
you know what Republicans you're right
Biden's got to go good luck good luck in
November because then they bring in
Gavin Newsome and they they would love
to get Joe Biden a swap out somehow with
gruesome Newsome yeah gruesome new we
couldn't even impeach my orcus who's
Homeland Security secretary who won't
enforce the border and you know he'd be
easier to impeach him we still haven't
done that I so I I hate the fact that
they are so in unable to do anything
like we're GNA talk you know we're gonna
have V ramaswami in the uh okay next
week and he's talking about making major
major Cuts real substantive Cuts Like I
would love to see the government just
shrink a little bit never mind you know
I mean well actually I would love to see
the government stop growing and stop
trying to in insert itself into you know
things that essentially are are personal
and stuff um but I mean I would I would
I would give you know just anything to
see it just stop growing you know just
stop first doing first stop doing more
harm yeah you know that's what you do
first thing you do is stop the bleeding
right thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net